so reality here today in Hollywood
trying to figure out what this thing is
now people calling a hoverboard but it
has wheels so what is this yeah what up
hey what is what is this thing I'm on
right now call the hoverboard it's a
some kind of roller the new electronic
roller skate thing nice perhaps just
like the movie I'm from Brazil in Brazil
called cigarettes under shopping would
you call it a hoverboard no why why is
it called a hover it isn't hover hmm
yeah what would you call this right here
got it
you think this is the future yes
so we're back at BuzzFeed and didn't get
any answers in the street so let's see
what people say around the office yeah
hey what do you call would you call this
thing
what is this hoverboard no yes
it's a Segway that doesn't have a handle
for your arms they're not actually hover
boards that's like completely blocked
but they can call it I know what is it I
don't know it's like some really fully
thing so here's what I learned guys this
could be called a Rollie pollie exactly
without handles I'll probably just an
interesting way to get around but all in
all it's just a future man
[Music]
hoverboards with a wheel this is a
hoverboard with a wheel